Ja, hallo und herzlich Willkommen zurück
auf meinem Kanal.
Wie schön, dass ihr wieder mit dabei seid.
Heute machen wir mal eine Gartentour.
Es ist jetzt bald April.
Also zeige ich euch mal, was gerade in unserem
Selbstversorger-Garten alles wächst und wie
ihr euer eigenes Gemüse anbauen könnt.
Falls ihr mich noch nicht kennt: Ich bin Marie.
Ich baue das Obst und Gemüse für meine Familie
fast komplett selber an und auf diesem Kanal
hier, da zeige ich euch, wie das geht.
Seht ihr die Kerle da oben auf dem Dach?
Sind die neuen Pfauen unserer Nachbarn.
Die haben gestern entschieden auf einem dreistöckigen
Haus zu übernachten.
Sind einfach hochgeflogen.
Ich hoffe sehr, dass die sich nicht allzu
sehr für meinen Gemüsegarten interessieren,
weil ich glaube nicht, dass ich sie davon
abhalten könnte meine Beete zu plündern,
wenn sie das unbedingt wollen.
In dem Beet hier hinter mir wachsen Weißkohl
und Feldsalat.
Den Weißkohl habe ich ziemlich spät letztes
Jahr gepflanzt.
Eigentlich ein bisschen zu spät.
Ich habe noch ziemlich spät im Jahr Pflänzchen
bekommen auf dem Jungpflanzenmarkt und dachte:
Ach komm, eine kleine Ernte wird das schon
geben.
Damit kann man nochmal einen kleinen Flecken
im Garten füllen, der sonst leerstehen würde
und das hat wirklich geklappt.
Ich glaube, ich habe die erst im September
gepflanzt.
Die haben hier im Beet überwintert und jetzt
sind die Köpfe zwar nicht riesig, aber wir
haben eine ganz frühe Weißkohlernte.
Es ist jetzt auch sinnvoll die nach und nach
zu ernten, weil die im zweiten Jahr ja anfangen
zu blühen.
Es sind zweijährige Pflanzen und die würden
jetzt anfangen Samenstände auszubilden demnächst,
deswegen sehen wir zu, dass wir die vorher
alle aufessen.
Der Feldsalat ist gerade noch ein bisschen
eingefroren, deswegen warte ich noch einen
Moment, bevor ich den ernte, weil wenn man
eingefrorene Pflanzen erntet, dann tauen die
zuhause auf und sind matschig, aber wenn man
die im Beet auftauen lässt, also die lebendige
Pflanze auftauen lässt, dann, bei den ganzen
winterharten Pflanzen, wachsen die einfach
weiter, sind wieder frisch und knackig und
dann kann man die ernten und sie sind genau
so, wie man es gewohnt ist zuhause, wenn man
sie dann essen möchte.
Ist ein bisschen so, wie man Tiefkühlspinat
auftaut, dann ist der ja auch ziemlich matschig
und nicht mehr so frisch und knackig.
Wenn die Pflanzen eingefroren sind, dann sollte
man die auch gar nicht anfassen, weil die
dadurch Schaden nehmen können und die komplett
in Ruhe lassen.
Auch nicht Unkraut jäten dann zwischen den
Pflanzen oder sonst irgendetwas, weil das
würde denen wirklich eher schaden als nutzen.
In diesem Beet da hinten wachsen vor allem
Blumen und Kräuter.
Ich habe eben lange Zeit keinen einzigen Flecken
in meinem Garten für Blumen gelassen, weil
ich unbedingt so viel Essen, wie möglich,
selber anbauen wollte.
Es gibt aber ja auch Blumen, die man essen
kann und selbst die, die man nicht essen kann,
gehören eben hier einfach in den Garten dazu.
Oder wie seht ihr das?
Auf jeden Fall kann man an diesem Beet etwas
ganz Spannendes sehen, und zwar lege ich meine
Beete ja mit Pappe und Kompost an.
Wie das genau funktioniert, zeige ich euch
in meinem Minikurs.
Das Gemüsegarten-Bootcamp ist kostenlos.
Könnt ihr euch gerne für anmelden.
Ich kann euch den Link nochmal in die Videobeschreibung
packen.
Da habe ich im ersten Video die komplette
Anleitung, wie man diese Beete anlegt.
Und wenn ihr das schon gesehen habt, dann
wisst ihr, dass man dafür Pappe braucht.
Und einige Leute fragen immer: Kann man die
Pappe weglassen?
Natürlich, die kann man auf jeden Fall weglassen.
Es hat nur den Unterschied, dass dann Unkraut
durchkommt.
Wir verwenden diese Beetanlegetechnik eben,
weil da kein Unkraut mehr in den Beeten wächst,
oder kaum noch Unkraut, und an der Stelle
hat uns die Pappe gefehlt.
Also da ist uns die Pappe ausgegangen und
wir haben dieses Beet ohne Pappe angelegt.
Und man merkt einen enormen Unterschied.
Also in dem Beet jäte ich ungefähr genauso
oft, wie in meinem ganzen, restlichen Garten.
So viel Gras und Unkraut kommt da immer noch
durch.
Das ist also der Unterschied.
Es funktioniert auch ohne, aber damit muss
man dann eben leben, dass man dann dafür
mehr Unkraut in seinen Beeten hat.
Ich kann euch gerne nochmal ein Video verlinken,
indem ich euch genau erzähle, wie man das
hinkriegt, dass man unkrautfrei gärtnert.
Das verlinke ich euch gerne mal da oben.
Oder ist es hier oben?
Ich glaube da oben.
Also ganz genau habe ich mir das immer noch
nicht gemerkt.
Ja, daneben stehen unsere Winterzwiebeln.
Die haben wir im Herbst gesteckt.
Das ist eine Sorte, die überwintert auf dem
Beet, die dann schon einen Wachstumsvorsprung
hat jetzt im Frühling.
Die können wir jetzt schon als Frühlingszwiebeln
ernten.
Wir können aber auch noch warten.
Ungefähr im Juli sind die dann erntereif,
genauso, wie andere Küchenzwiebeln auch.
Das ist eine ganz tolle Sache.
Das mache ich auch jedes Jahr und jetzt im
Frühling ist die Zeit, wo man zwischen den
Winterzwiebeln die Möhren aussähen kann.
Das ist eine ganz tolle Mischkultur, Möhren
und Zwiebeln, und das werde ich auf jeden
Fall machen.
Im Moment ist es noch sehr, sehr kalt.
Es ist für mehrere Tage Frost angekündigt,
deswegen warte ich noch mit den (Aussaaten?).
Es ist immer ganz klug, wenn man da so ein
bisschen den Wetterbericht im Blick hat, sodass
man die Samen nicht unbedingt dann in die
Erde gibt, wenn es gerade ganz, ganz, ganz
kalt ist draußen.
Dann kommt unser Rettichbeet.
Das wird jetzt auch abgeerntet, weil ich Sorge
habe, dass die anfangen zu blühen.
Daraus werde ich ein schönes Sauerkraut machen,
einen Rettichsauerkraut.
Man kann ja alle möglichen Gemüse fermentieren
und ich denke, dass das sehr lecker sein wird.
Also habe ich Rettich schon oft verwendet
und finde den da super gut.
Ich habe einen Gärtopf, der gerade voll geworden
ist.
Also werden wir nachher noch unser kleines
Rettichsauerkraut ansetzen.
Ja und hier wachsen meine dicken Bohnen.
Die sind auch gerade etwas eingefroren.
Die richten sich dann wieder auf, wenn es
wärmer wird.
Denen macht Frost auch gar nichts aus, so,
wie allen Gemüsen, die ich euch jetzt hier
zeige in dieser Gartentour.
Die haben alle den ganzen Winter überstanden
auf den Beeten.
Dicke Bohnen haben einen Feind, nämlich die
schwarze Bohnenlaus.
Die werden davon ganz stark und ganz oft befallen
und ich habe die Beobachtung gemacht, dass,
wenn man die dicken Bohnen im Spätsommer
aussät, also ungefähr im August, dann in
den Beeten überwintern lässt, dass die dicke
Bohnenlaus sich dann eher von den Pflanzen
fernhält.
Also, dass sie dann widerstandsfähiger gegen
die Bohnenläuse sind.
Deswegen lasse ich die immer überwintern.
Man könnte die auch im Frühling erst sähen,
aber so haben die auch schon einen Wachstumsvorsprung
und können dann hoffentlich bald ganz viele,
dicke Bohnen produzieren.
Da sind auf jeden Fall schon ganz viele Blüten
dran und ich freue mich schon.
Das ist so mit eine der ersten Ernten, die
man dann im Frühling von den neuen Gemüsen
ernten kann.
Seht ihr diesen tollen Baum hier hinter mir?
Der ist wunderschön, aber leider ein kleines
Problem für unser Gemüse.
Das ist nämlich eine Walnuss, und Walnüsse
sondern Stoffe ab, die andere Pflanzen unterdrücken
im Wachstum, weil die alle Nährstoffe und
das ganze Wasser für sich haben wollen.
Das sind schon kleine Egoisten, die Walnüsse,
und wir merken das sehr stark an unseren Beeten.
Die sind hier direkt an der Walnuss.
Also hier ist unser Gemüsegarten und genau
daneben wächst die Walnuss.
Und gerade die Beete, die direkt an der Walnuss
dran liegen, da merken wir, dass das Gemüse
sehr, sehr, sehr schlecht wächst.
Deswegen haben wir da zwei Hochbeete hingestellt,
aber die anderen beiden Beete, die auch hier
direkt dran sind, da merkt man das auch richtig,
richtig stark – also diesen Einfluss von
der Walnuss.
Ich habe zum Beispiel letztes Jahr hier rote
Beete gesät und die hat immer noch keine
Knollen ausgebildet.
Dabei wächst rote Beete eigentlich normalerweise
ohne viel Zutun und ich bin echt ein bisschen
ratlos, ob ich jetzt hier nochmal Hochbeete
hinstellen soll.
Irgendwie habe ich da eigentlich keine Lust
drauf.
Ich finde es irgendwie netter ebenerdig zu
gärtnern, weil man dann weniger gießen muss,
weil man nicht den Aufwand hat, dass man Hochbeete
bauen muss.
Ihr könnt mir gerne mal schreiben, wenn ihr
irgendwelche Vorschläge habt, aber das bereitet
mir schon ein bisschen Kummer, weil das sind
immerhin, ja, zwei große Beete, die uns so
verloren gehen oder auf denen wir quasi kein
Gemüse anbauen können, weil es einfach nicht
wachsen will.
In den Hochbeeten selber, da wächst alles
gut.
Da ist ja die Erde ausgetauscht, sodass die
Pflanzen gar nicht mit dem Mutterboden in
Kontakt kommen, die durch die Walnuss verpestet
wurde, aber da ist so der große Unterschied,
dass ich ja meinen Garten möglichst wenig
gießen will und ich bin es nicht so ganz
gewohnt, dass ich die Hochbeete trotzdem gieße,
weil in den Hochbeeten verdunstet ganz viel
Wasser.
Die werden super schnell trocken und das ist
so mein kleiner Kampf mit den Hochbeeten,
dass ich da hinterher sein muss mit dem Gießen
und da dran denken muss.
Ist genauso, wie im Gewächshaus.
Da muss ich mich auch immer dran erinnern,
weil das Gießen einfach normalerweise nicht
auf meiner Garten to-do-Liste steht.
Deswegen sind unsere ebenerdigen Beete auf
jeden Fall ertragreicher, als die Hochbeete,
weil wenn ich mich einfach mal am Riemen reiße,
dann würden die auch richtig gut Gemüse
produzieren.
Ich muss einfach nur an das blöde Gießen
denken.
Ja, die Hochbeete sind größtenteils abgeerntet.
Da hatten wir Spinat drin und einige, andere
Gemüse und die haben wir jetzt aufgefüllt
mit neuem Kompost und da können wir jetzt,
wenn der Frost vorbei ist, die ersten, neuen
Gemüse einsähen.
Der Asia-Salat, den wir hier in den Hochbeeten
haben, der wächst übrigens super, super
gut.
Absoluter Anbautipp, wenn ihr auf Asia-Salat
steht, das ist eine tolle Möglichkeit, um
im Winter immer noch ganz viel (Grünzeug?)
aus dem eigenen Garten zu essen.
Da kann man echt/ Den kann man regelmäßig
extrem krass abernten und das wächst immer
wieder nach und lässt sich nicht beirren,
auch in kalten Temperaturen einfach weiter
zu wachsen.
Ja hier ist das zweite Beet, das auch so von
der Walnuss beeinträchtigt ist.
Hier wächst unser Wintersalat.
Die Sorte ist Baquieu.
Die haben ja einige von euch jetzt auch schon
angebaut, nachdem ich die eigentlich in jedem
Video, wo sich das anbietet, irgendwie anpreise.
Das ist eine ganz tolle Salatsorte, die man
den ganzen Winter über beernten kann.
Leider wächst der aufgrund der Walnuss nicht
so super dieses Jahr, aber immerhin, sodass
wir immer noch genug eigenen Salat ernten
können.
Was ich jetzt mache, ist, dass ich, wenn es
jetzt wirklich kalt wird, – es soll jetzt
nochmal richtig starke Minusgrade geben – dann
werde ich den mit einem Fließ abdecken.
Ich habe ja diese Bogenstangen schon aufgebaut
und da kann ich jetzt auch ein Gärtnervlies
drüber packen, um den Salat ein bisschen
einzumummeln, damit der uns nicht matschig
zerfriert, aber normalerweise übersteht der
auch starke Minusgrade wunderbar.
Dann kommen die drei Beete, auf denen wir
unseren Winterkohl hatten.
Wir hatten da vor allem Wirsing und Rosenkohl
und auch ein bisschen Sellerie noch mit dazwischen
– der ist ja auch relativ frosthart.
Und die haben wir jetzt allesamt abgeerntet.
Ein Wirsing steht noch da.
Nein, zwei.
Ja, weil die jetzt anfangen zu blühen.
Also, wenn du Rosenkohl und Wirsing noch in
deinen Beeten hast, dann fange mal an den
aufzuessen, weil der fängt jetzt an zu schießen.
Der will jetzt kleine Rosenkohlbabys und Wirsingbabys
machen und dann ist es gut, wenn man den vorher
aufisst, weil der dann eben nicht mehr so
lecker schmeckt, wenn der einmal angefangen
hat zu blühen.
Die Beete sind jetzt frei für die nächsten
Aussaaten.
Ich werde da ein paar Zwiebeln stecken und
dann später Paprika und Auberginen anbauen.
Die haben noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Die können ja jetzt noch nicht in den Garten.
Alle wärmeliebenden Pflanzen müssen bis
Mitte Mai warten, bis man die in den Garten
auspflanzen kann, aber ich pflanze eben vorher
schon mal ein paar schnell wachsendere, kleinere
Gemüse, sodass wir dann die Paprika dazwischen
pflanzen können.
Und bis die Paprika den ganzen Platz braucht,
werden wir dann die Zwiebeln schon abgeerntet
haben und so können wir das Beet dann noch
mehr nutzen, weil jetzt steht das leer und
es wäre einfach schade den ganzen Platz bis
Mitte Mai jetzt nicht nutzen zu können.
Dahinten hat mein Sohn sein Beet.
Das ist immer das schönste Beet im ganzen
Garten, weil der sich nicht zu schade ist
Blumen zu pflanzen und da immer ganz viel
blüht in seinem Beet.
Der hat auch ganz viele Erdbeeren gepflanzt
letztes Jahr und Knoblauch, und die wachsen
auch schon richtig gut.
Daneben ist ein Beet, das eben frei geworden
ist.
Da haben wir ja schon die nächste Baquieu-Salat
gepflanzt und da werden wir jetzt auch rote
Beete sähen.
Dann kommen Stangenbohnen noch dazu.
Das ist eine tolle Mischkultur, rote Beete
und Stangenbohnen, und ich liebe das auch
so Stangenbohnen anzubauen mit so einem schönen
Gerüst.
Ist einfach super hübsch, oder?
Die haben auch so schöne Blüten.
Gerade so Feuerbohnen, da freue ich mich auf
jeden Fall schon, wenn die endlich in die
Erde kommen.
An der Stelle, wo die Stangenbohnen hinkommen
sollen, wächst jetzt noch der Baquieu-Salat.
Das ist wieder so eine Abfolge, sodass wir
das Beet jetzt schon nutzen können und dann,
wenn die Stangenbohnen gesät werden können,
was auch erst später im Jahr ist, dann ist
der Baquieu-Salat schon so groß, dass man
ihn ernten kann, bevor die Stangenbohnen den
Platz komplett brauchen.
Es ist super sinnvoll sich zu überlegen,
welche Gemüse den Platz im Beet wie lange
beanspruchen, sodass man eben diese Zwischenpflanzungen
machen kann, sodass man das genau takten kann,
dass die Beete das ganze Jahr über genutzt
sind.
Wenn ihr keine Lust habt euch den Kopf zu
zerbrechen oder ein bisschen Inspiration wollt,
wie ich das mache, dann ladet euch gerne meinen
Gartenplan herunter.
Der ist auch kostenlos.
Den Link packe ich euch auch in die Videobeschreibung.
Dann habt ihr einen fertigen Plan, wo ihr
gar nicht mehr nachdenken müsst, sondern
einfach rausgehen könnt und anfangen könnt
euer Gemüse selber anzubauen.
Ja, dann gibt es natürlich noch das Gewächshaus.
Da haben wir jetzt auch schon Gemüse drin.
Da waren die Hühner zwischenzeitlich im Winter
mal drin, haben da ein paar Wochen (gelebt?),
den Boden schön mit ihrem Dünger angereichert
und da den Boden vorbereitet.
Dann haben wir noch Kompost ausgebracht.
Damit haben wir hier auch noch ein neues Beet
angelegt.
Da bin ich schon sehr gespannt, was ich da
rein pflanzen will.
Das ist nämlich in meinem jetzigen Gartenplan
noch gar nicht berücksichtigt.
Ich bin gerade stark für Kräuter, aber wer
weiß, was mir da noch einfällt.
Es gibt immer etwas, was man pflanzen kann,
oder?
In das Gewächshaus kommen dann demnächst
Ende April, je nach dem, wie das Wetter wird,
die Tomaten, Paprika.
Wir wollen auch eine Wassermelone im Gewächshaus
anbauen.
Da freue ich mich auch schon drauf.
Hoffentlich wird das etwas.
Wir hatten schon Wassermelonen im Freiland.
Die haben schon eine Ernte abgeworfen, aber
die Früchte sind sehr klein geblieben, also
schauen wir mal, wie das mit der Gewächshaus-Wassermelone
dieses Jahr laufen wird.
Ein paar Erdnüsse will ich ins Gewächshaus
pflanzen.
Die entwickeln sich übrigens prächtig.
Das passende Video kann ich euch hier oben
verlinken.
Ich werde dieses Jahr Erdnüsse anbauen und
das mal ausprobieren, ob die wirklich in Deutschland
wachsen.
Ein paar werde ich ins Freiland pflanzen,
ein paar ins Gewächshaus, damit wir das besser
vergleichen können.
Und bisher wachsen im Gewächshaus Zwiebeln,
Spinat und Mangold.
Das sind alles Kulturen, die relativ schnell
wachsen.
Die Zwiebeln wollen wir nur für Frühlingszwiebeln
anbauen, sodass der Platz dann, wenn die Tomaten
und die Paprika einziehen, größtenteils
von denen genutzt werden kann, weil das uns
wichtiger ist, dass wir da möglichst viel
Platz für haben, weil wir super viele Tomaten
anbauen möchten.
Das ist der Spinat.
Schön am Rand, hier sind überall Zwiebeln
gesteckt, ein paar Jungpflanzen und da hinten
wächst der Mangold.
Und ein kleiner Baquieu.
Natürlich, wie sollte es anders sein?
In der Wohnung, wo wir vorher gewohnt haben,
da wächst sogar immer noch Baquieu in den
Fugen der Auffahrt.
Habe ich letztens gesehen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie der dahin gekommen ist,
aber wir hinterlassen unsere Spuren.
Ich habe alle Kulturen, die jetzt im Gewächshaus
wachsen am Rand gesät und gepflanzt, sodass
ich die Tomaten schon ins Gewächshaus pflanzen
kann, während diese Gemüse noch drin stehen
und die möglichst wenig Platz einnehmen und
die Tomaten schon mal anfangen können zu
wachsen.
Und sobald die Tomaten dann größer sind
und die Paprika und was auch immer da alles
noch gepflanzt wird, sind der Spinat und der
Mangold und auch die Zwiebeln hoffentlich
schon alle aufgegessen.
Dieser Garten hier, den haben wir vor allem
für das Feingemüse.
Also für die Kulturen, die mehr Aufmerksamkeit
brauchen.
Das ganze Ackergemüse wächst bei uns in
einem anderen Garten.
Da kann ich euch auch nochmal eine Tour geben,
wenn wir da alles vorbereitet haben und dann
kann ich auch zeigen, wie wir alles vorbereiten.
Da wachsen dann Kartoffeln, Kürbis, Mais,
noch mehr Zwiebeln, viel mehr Zwiebeln, Möhren,
Pastinaken und so diese ganzen Gemüse, die
auch ohne viel Aufmerksamkeit ganz gut weiter
wachsen und von denen man richtig große Mengen
braucht, wenn man sich selber versorgen möchte.
Das ist also unser Acker und hier haben wir
das ganze Gemüse, das man auch regelmäßig
beerntet und das ein bisschen mehr Pflege
und Aufmerksamkeit braucht, weil der Acker
ziemlich weit entfernt liegt.
Da müssen wir dann immer mit dem Auto hinfahren
und das machen wir nur alle paar Wochen.
So, ich bin gerade dabei das Sauerkraut zu
machen aus dem schwarzen Rettich.
Sauerkraut ist es ja eigentlich gar nicht,
aber ich fermentiere das nach dem gleichen
Prinzip.
Ich kann euch gerne mal eine Anleitung zum
Gemüse-Fermentieren unten in die Videobeschreibung
packen.
Da habe ich jede Menge, tolle Informationen
auf meinem Blog.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das am Ende schmecken
wird.
So in der Form habe ich das noch nicht ausprobiert
und ja, ich höre ganz herrlich gerade Musik.
Also wundert euch nicht, wenn ich nebenbei
ein bisschen tanze, weil das mache ich einfach
super gerne.
Ich habe auch gerade so einen Ohrwurm.
Weiß nicht, ob ihr das Lied kennt.
Das heißt Scarlet Paintings und irgendwie
höre ich das rauf und runter, jeden Tag.
Da drüben habe ich euch ein Video verlinkt,
in dem ich euch zeige, wie wir es schaffen
unser Gemüse und unser Obst in drei Stunden
pro Woche komplett selber anzubauen.
Da unten findet ihr auch noch ein spannendes
Video.
Ich freue mich, wenn wir uns gleich da oder
da wieder sehen.
Habt noch einen wunderschönen Tag.
Bis dann, tschüss!